Recall that we started the lesson with
this idea for multiplying polynomials.
Convert to the value representation,
multiply the polynomials there,
just by multiplying the corresponding
values, and then convert back.
Rounding up to the nearest power of 2,
we might have written these
running times like so,
in terms of our parameter N.
With the Fast Fourier Transform,
we were able to do the evaluation,
not in quadratic time, but
on linearithmic time and log N.
And even more remarkably,
we were able to apply this same trick
to do the interpolation as well.
We just had to pass in
the inverse of the root of unity
that we had used in the evaluation.
The conclusion is that order N
polynomials can be multiplied in order N
log N time.
Remember that polynomial multiplication
was just a convenient way to think about
the more general problem of convolution.
Therefore, in general, convolving an N
long sequence with an m long sequence
takes time on the order of n+m
times the log of n+m operations.
This is a truly remarkable and
powerful result.